in una città qualunque
sono le sette di mattina di un giorno
qualunque in un mese qualunque voi siete
son bou su un bus qualunque estate
andando in ufficio o un ufficio
qualunque no signora non scende alla
prossima
ecco il vostro cellulare inizia già a
vibrare delle prime notifiche della
giornata delle notifiche qualunque ma
notifica che comunque non potete
ignorare
siete proprio lì alisa rispondere ai
vostri primi messaggi della giornata dei
messaggi qualunque quando il bus frena
di colpo qualcuno vi urta e si scusa
scendete la vostra fermata che andate al
solito edicolante un edicolante
qualunque a comprare il vostro
quotidiano preferito un quotidiano o
qualunque ma ecco che una qualunque
ordinaria giornata sta per trasformarsi
in un momento che vostro malgrado
difficilmente dimenticherete
mettete mano al portafogli e non lo
trovate eppure eravate così convinti di
averlo portato con voi messo al sicuro
nella vostra tasca ed è là che mi viene
in mente quel signore distinto che dopo
aver visitato si è scusato un signore
distinto qualunque signori sono tiziano
grigioni e sono uno di quelli che hanno
deciso di fare del vostro portafogli il
proprio stipendio
sì esatto signora sono un borseggiatore
ma non un borseggiatore qualunque no
sono un borseggiatore da palcoscenico
questo significa che sul palco rubo
oggetti dalle tasche delle persone ma il
mio ego si nutre talmente tanto di
applausi da impormi di farmi scoprire
subito a a proposito di furti di
applausi di un appena rubato uno grazie
la mia disciplina in gergo è definita
pickpocketing ed è un'arte decisamente
molto simile all'illusionismo ecco ma
com'è possibile che un tizio tanto
assurdo conciato come me voglio dire
avete visto che barba riesco a mettervi
le mani in tasca e da sottrarvi a vostra
insaputa i vostri effetti personali
grazie a quella che gli americani
definiscono misdirection il depistaggio
mentale l'arte vera e propria di
indirizzare e condizionare l'attenzione
degli spettatori è quindi possibile
davvero controllare l'attenzione
dell'essere umano
al punto da prevederne i propri
atteggiamenti in base ai nostri stimoli
la risposta è sì è possibile e non
bisogna di certo essere un supereroe di
stanley per farlo nonostante io
nonostante gli assomiglia un cartone
animato misdirection si è ovvio non
esiste un pulsante on off in grado di
attivare o disattivare la nostra
sorveglianza mentale
eppure la miss direction e sotto gli
occhi di tutti costantemente tutti voi
seduti in platea anch'io
noi siamo vittime inconsapevoli ci si
distrae di continuo
oddio ho un pelo bianco nella barba che
non ho nemmeno compiuto 30 anni e passo
le prossime due ore davanti allo
specchio a vedere questo lento declino
da giovane ladro barbuto alla copia più
hipster di santa claus ci si distrae di
continuo anche per i motivi più futili
il problema problema di tutti è che
siamo in questa epoca moderna
costantemente bersagliati da
informazioni come dardi come fece ci
arrivano
il guaio è che non riusciamo a
concentrarci nessuno nessun l'altro no
li riceviamo tutti e tutti assieme a tal
punto da non focalizzare la nostra
attenzione su quello veramente
importante o comunque su quello che
preferiamo
vi faccio un esempio immaginate per
favore di vivere in una in un piccolo
paesino un piccolo paesino dove tutti vi
conoscono e tutti si conoscono
non avete a vostra disposizione una
grande varietà di intrattenimento e i
pochi libri della vostra biblioteca
privata li conoscete ormea memoria vita
tranquilla no noioso oserei dire per un
diabolik da esposizione come il
sottoscritto
ecco ora immaginate di vivere invece in
una grande metropoli in espansione come
gotham city
esatto alla città di batman dove nessuno
vi conosce e ogni persona che ha
incontrato
un potenziale amico nemico amante luoghi
da visitare pericoli da da schivare e da
eludere
ecco questa è la vostra mente una una
città una metropoli in perenne
espansione 24 ore su 24 anche durante le
ore di sonno
tradotto nel concreto quando chiamò sul
palco uno spettatore e tento di
sottrargli il portafogli e quant'altro
la prima cosa che faccio è constatare se
nella tasca la qualche oggetto al di là
del portafogli o il caro amico mio che
di bella giacca dopo il posso chiederle
dove l'ha comprata ed ecco che
l'attenzione dello spettatore e sulla
giacca
anzi quasi compiaciuto mi sta chiedendo
dello comprato questa giacca la mia
moglie mi ha fatto i complimenti anche
lui mi stai facendo i complimenti per
questa superba giacca quindi la l'idea
di farsi derubare è totalmente fuori
degli schemi cognitivi così come questi
peli sono fuori dei mediando dalle mie
ghiandole pilifere amico mino la
consideri denaro ed ecco che dalla
giacca l'attenzione passa al portafogli
non si rende però conto che con l'altra
mano gli appena rubato lo smartphone
dalla tasca
ecco questa sensazione di straniamento
non vi è familiare quante volte arrivate
a fine giornata a casa con questo senso
di vuoto
magari vi eravate prefissati degli
obiettivi e non gli avete portati a
termine perché perché punto vi siete
lasciati trascinare dagli eventi dalle
situazioni non avete focalizzato la
vostra attenzione
ma vi siete lasciati mettere barriere
dalle vostre distrazioni del quotidiano
ad esempio arrivata in ufficio arrivata
in ufficio e sulla scrivania trovata è
già a due posti gialli riccardo rossi va
richiamato e la ditta qualcosa vuole un
nuovo preventivo
accendete il pc e trovate sette mail a
cui rispondere dovete rispondere subito
e poi ancora telefonate news notifiche
comunicazioni finalmente la pausa pranzo
e cosa fate controllate facebook quindi
ancora notifiche news e comunicazioni
e ancora la ricetta del ghana per la
carbonara perché si esiste una carbonara
vegana l'ennesimo sacerdote che ammessa
cante ricchi e poveri
l'amico il vostro ex compagno di scuola
che vi invita al suo matrimonio in
comune con comunione di beni mentre
l'amico in comunica von post irritato
perché l'amico in comune non l'ha
invitato in comune al matrimonio con
comunione di beni e ancora il loro scopo
la 37a copertina per lo stesso sempre
identico volume di harry potter volo più
hotel a zanzibar tutto compreso 350 euro
hashtag ciao
clicca qui per sapere come fare e foto
di gattini
a tutti piacciono le foto di gattini
signora un vecchio vaso sulla tv un
gatto bianco con gli occhi blu
no il sacerdote che canta ricchi e
poveri come che faceva
ecco ovviamente passa la pausa pranzo
non avete dato neanche un morso al
vostro panino si sta ragionando per
eccessi questo è vero ma anche una
qualunque giornata tipo poco stellar si
di difficoltà di imprevisti di
disattenzione
io da giovane e millenni al quindi nato
a cavallo tra gli anni 90 e 2000 sono
abituato o quantomeno mi dichiaro
abituato a vivere a notare in questo
mare frenetico che ogni giorno ci ci
sovrasta in realtà non è affatto così
non è affatto così tutti noi ci
distraiamo io appunto in primis perché
nessuno nessuno ci impone di controllare
le mail sette volte al minuto
nessuno ci vieta di di spegnere il wifi
per almeno una manciata di ore al giorno
eppure telefono squilla dealing l'on lo
prendo e metto like alla foto in cui
sono stato pagato soprattutto se nella
foto ci sono gattini è impossibile
veramente farne a meno ma impossibile
farne a meno ma quindi quanto tempo noi
sottraiamo a noi stessi perché di questo
che si parla del tempo la sensazione di
vuoto che provate a fine giornata è la
stessa sensazione di vuoto che provano
le vostre tasche
dopo un incontro truffaldino con il
sottoscritto ma ben più importante di
uno smartphone è il l'oggetto della
vostra mancanza
si signori sto parlando della moneta più
preziosa che tutti noi abbiamo il tempo
a quanto ammonta quindi il tempo che
perdiamo
secondo una ricerca di mercato del 2016
condotta da media key xché è un'agenzia
di influencer marketing statunitense si
stima che trascorriamo circa due ore al
giorno sui social in particolare su
youtube facebook e instagram
questo fa sì facendo un rapido calcolo
che trascorriamo sulle reti di
comunicazione sociale ben 5 anni e 4
mesi della nostra vita
considerando che almeno tre anni li
passo sicuramente a pettinarmi la barba
la scorta di sabbia nella clessidra è
effettivamente in esaurimento
5 anni e 4 mesi amici miei cinque anni e
quattro mesi in 5 anni e 4 mesi potremmo
andare a piedi sulla grande muraglia
cinese avanti e indietro per tre volte
in 5 anni e 4 mesi potremo andare sulla
luna 32 volte in 5 anni e 4 mesi
potremmo guardare i simpson tutti gli
episodi puntate speciali incluse 215
volte 5 anni e 4 mesi
il problema è che noi crediamo di essere
in una frenetica modernità
effettivamente siamo in una frenetica
modernità ma non è da incolpare gli
altri spesso ci ritroviamo a vedere noi
come non lo so vittime di disattenzione
e mai come colpevoli di distrazione
sempre vittime nonostante adesso se ci
fate caso le pubblicità che vedete in tv
durano un decimo di quelle che passavano
vent'anni fa per come la nostra soglia
attentiva è sempre più breve e della
stessa cosa che faccio io quando mettono
le mani nelle tasche delle persone
lavoro su questo lavoro su questo
ecco l'uomo da sempre è alla costante
ricerca di stimoli sensoriali che
vengono dall'esterno anche
involontariamente pensate che già nel
1600 una persona a caso tale blaise
pascal diceva che il guaio dell'uomo che
non riesce a starsene tranquillo in una
stanza da solo e come dargli torto
ma come soccombere quindi a questa
mancanza di tempo come far sì che le
nostre difese d'attenzione siano muri di
cemento armato
ecco appare il mio dovremmo intanto
saper discernere tutto ciò che è utile e
piacevole da ciò che è superfluo appunto
non dimenticate il piacevole non
dimenticate il piacevole come la birra
al pub con gli amici il sabato sera o la
vacanza con la vostra dolce metà
soprattutto se a zanzibar 350 euro e
vuole portare tutto compreso e
ovviamente quando sentite imparato a
riconoscere appunto le sensazioni che
sperimentate nella vostra testa quando
sentire di stare per distrarvi staccate
pausa 25 minuti e poi tornate al lavoro
questo farà sì che voi sarete sempre più
soddisfatti del vostro operato e che
possiate per seguire le vostre passioni
ma come ricondurre tutto ciò all'arte
truffaldina dei furti da palcoscenico
signori ho parlato troppo
c'è per caso tra voi un volontario mi
hanno detto che lo staff del ted ha
scelto per me una vittima una vittima
che si presterà per questo spettacolo e
che mi
basterà questa volta senza punta al
contenuto delle sue tasche dove sei
eccolo qua un forte applauso per lui
grazie ciao tiziano come ti chiami
francesco un applauso per francesco
eccolo qua
francesco meraviglioso no francesco si è
già stato sul palco
no però ti vedo propenso alla scena se
ben piantato non è meraviglioso
francesco ecco mi raccomando però è bene
che tu sia d'aiuto un secondo ok ok
meraviglioso il teatro francesco non si
danno mai le spalle al pubblico perciò
guarda qua sorridi un applauso per
francesco di nuovo grazie mille
francesco francesco francesco immagina
di stare sul bus
sì il bus degli hobbit non francesco il
boss meraviglioso francesco ora tutte le
persone sul boss francesco sono attente
al contenuto delle proprie tasche e
soprattutto il portafogli ai quante un
portafogli posso vederlo un secondo o
nel mentre francese si può lasciare il
bus per il momento soltanto o signore e
signori il ladro si appropinqua del
portafogli della vittima
il furto più veloce della storia grazie
no francesco mi rendo conto che davanti
a questa platea tata insomma questo è un
po una truffa nella truffa
no facciamo una di una dimostrazione più
veritiera ok il portafogli al sicuro
nella tua tasca meraviglioso possiamo
cominciare ti chiede appunto di prendere
il borsa di fare un passo avanti
ottimo francesco farmi controllare stai
vaianesi stai benissimo
questo è importante le spalle tutto
fosse ok francesco francesco una cosa
come fa il ladro ad appropriarsi degli
oggetti della vittima mediante quello
che è definito metodo per rom ma che non
c'entra nulla con la california del
trentino draw distrazione reazione
obiettivo distrazione o che bella giacca
dotti più che a francesco posso vederla
meraviglioso e qui adesso la sua soglia
dell'attenzione è totalmente distante
dal fatto che voglio rubargli il
portafogli assolutamente reazione
francesco appunto pensa ad altro non si
rende conto che sto controllando il
contenuto delle sue tasche interne amici
miei
obiettivo il ladro si appropria
dell'oggetto della vittima o almeno
questo succederebbe se fossimo sul bus
invece di siamo sul palco mi sembrava
scontato il brutto rubarti le cose
giustamente sul palco giusto perfetto
signori questo vuol dire che il metodo
funziona francesco impegnato com'era a
pensare al tuo portafogli non ti sei
reso conto che qualcos'altro ti manca e
due cellulari e signori il cellulare di
francesco un applauso
[Risate]
ma signori francesco torna pure qua dove
scappi manca qualcos'altro all'appello
il tuo portafogli grazie mille francesco
vieni qua un inchino vai francesco forza
forte come passato a fi questo porta in
pieno e vai pure grazie mille francesco
da francesco deve fare una persona
elegante come te senza la cravatta
signore e signori per poi francesco e la
sua cravatta
grazie mille francesco puoi andare
signori però ci da tiziano grigioni il
vostro hipster trickster è davvero tutto
sono stato felicissimo di essere qui di
essere stato poi con voi siete il
pubblico migliore che abbia avuto oggi
spero che il tempo da voi non so messo a
disposizione per questa performance sia
tempo che mi abbiate regalato e non
tempo che borso tratto grazie
[Musica]